let's go next to our caller from the
three six zero area code who's calling
today from three six zero hey what's
going on you know you know what's going
on hey who's this hi this is Casey it's
such a it's such a pleasure to be on
your show mr. Patman great well my
question is in regards to Andrew Yang's
recent CNN appearance how do you think
you know the audience sort of played
into that do you think CNN really does
screen these questions or what do you
think exactly goes on there
I have heard different things about
different town halls there are times
where CNN is very carefully vetting the
people but they have in the end asked
different questions than they told CNN
they were going to ask I think generally
speaking most of these networks have the
person's question written down for them
in case they get nervous or whatever but
I don't really know that much about what
they did for Andrew Yang's Town Hall no
I you know I don't know either I mean
especially like going back to these
other people tell me you don't know what
the people are gonna say you don't know
what the people are saying if you're CNN
you it's unpredictable what someone's
gonna say when you put the microphone in
front of them yeah yeah sure I mean yeah
you know the way that I would imagine
they do it is they have experience doing
this stuff so they will start talking to
people and try to assess whether they
seem like Loose Cannons who are lying
about what they're going to ask and you
know maybe they get up there and they
make a just instead of me asking a
question they just slam CNN or something
like that and I it hasn't really
happened much I mean what's really
common is that people who are actually
political activists slide in we talked
about how in I believe it was Bernie CNN
Town Hall a bunch of supposed
students and different people were
actually connected to lobbying firms and
all sorts of different stuff that seems
to get by a lot of these channels unless
they know about it and are fine with it
which doesn't seem like the most likely
thing it seems they're actually slipping
by Wow
all right Manuel great to talk to you
today okay much giggling oh yeah thanks
I appreciate the phone call very much
seems like he was outdoors near vehicles
when the call started but then got
inside which was nice